[Aplausos]
antes de mais queremos expressar nossa
profunda gratidão por estarmos neste
momento único então oficial há cerca de
14 anos atrás éramos um casal com
inspirações completamente nos filmes
acabado os nossos cursos superiores
eu como fumar era o menor com engenheiro
de sistemas e computadores
tínhamos acabado de casar e não seja
construir uma vida em comum se auto
descoberta ao longo da nossa caminhada é
que a mudança é uma constante e que
devemos ouvir a fala para evoluir na
vida e sobre essa mudança que viemos cá
falar hoje é sobre a forma como vamos
proteger as nações se ao nós acreditamos
profundamente é que todos nós temos um
propósito muito específico para
materializar aqui na vida ea vida
encarrega do vapor quente ao também
classificados para nós pensarmos esse
mesmo propósito
a mesma teve um momento decisivo na sua
vida quando após alguma insatisfação o
bastante satisfação a atacar e ser
usuário de enfermagem a cerca na altura
cerca de quatro anos
ela estava de licença de maternidade com
nosso filhotes em casa e de um programa
na tv e sportv estava era relacionado
com o mundial2006 do futebol e em si
convidado uma queda e designer naquela
altura para fazer um bolo ela vou bolo
alusivo à seleção portuguesa e é que o
erro imediatamente a maria joão ficou
preso o ecrã e ficou logo agarrada que o
conceito e a partir daí foi o que
disputou um clico novo mel
sim eu fiquei fixo muito olhar com a
televisão como apaixonada que só por
sorte além da saúde e lembra que ter
esse pensamento será que isto vai tirar
da informação só de alguns dias por ter
falado com esta crise nas compras de
materiais básicos em mãos à obra para
criar o meu primeiro golo que os meus
olhos daquela altura é tentava bonzinho
e os quase nem consigo olhar pra ele é
este momento que os outro muito
importante foi o joão tem uma postura
muito o que falar de cara e fazer o gol
batizado nosso primeiro filho e esgoto
avisado quando ela o mostrou a e atenção
a esta filha única foi executada dizer
que a única vez que o anjo da copa um
bolo e você percebe porquê porque é que
o urso e é meu não há mais comentários
nunca mais e o que aconteceu aí foi
muito importante porque quando o ela o
gol botou dodô batizado de festa com
suas bebidas são de amigos famílias e
até o chefe da assessoria do próprio
tela dizer qual está espetacular e aí
fiquei com ele
a série que vão ver o meu povo dessa
forma confesso que fiquei feliz mas em
simultâneo isso foi como uma confirmação
do caminho potencial que estava a pensar
se unir e também ao mesmo tempo não
surgindo aquelas dúvidas daqueles medir
tudo de cima todas aquelas inimigos
também que surgem quando vamos habilitar
uma mudança e ea e como surgiram vários
os principais foram como é que eu vou
dizer os meus pais eu vou abdicar de
algo que resultaram para mudar
como é que eu ia largar algo pelo qual
eu tinha depositado também os sonhos os
seus desejos suas ambições e também o
seu investimento necessário para poder
dar aquela carreira como é que eu ia
largar aqui o que era certo futuro por
algo que é tão incerto e inseguro mas na
verdade eu queria mudar e acredita em
muitas vezes que estava ficando maluca
isto vou a maria joão continuará a
acompanhar a fazer bolos para alguns
amigos a outra família citar alguns
clientes com souza ser e após um mau
jornada a longa da javari largos anos
há muita resistência altos e baixos três
filhos em casa tem mais dois em cima e
tudo que está inerente
o que aconteceu foi que sou é ser
reconhecida pelos media e mais que 50 do
ano passado um ser a que nós passamos a
nossa coisas não faz mal e é uma das
coisas que ela quer voltar atrás porque
isso é importante dizer que é quando a
maria joão queria fazer a sua mudança
estava com muito medo
eu tenho lido um livro maravilhoso que
este mesmo que está aqui quer mexer no
caso
e isso ele fala sobre a mudança e uma
das coisas sobre importados que o disco
el salvador licença e frio vai sentar
aqui e fazer este livro e não sais
enquanto na outra minados e office
center no nosso farol livro em duas
horas
este livro é fantástico é e passado esse
tempo eu continuava cheio favor e do
medo de fazer essa mudança
mas ao mesmo tempo que queria mudar e
quando acabei de ler o livro sabe
exatamente o que eu queria fazer muito
conquistar se tem e fechar em enfermagem
para trás e tinha que avançar para
estudantes e isso levou então esse
momento em que ela acabou por ser
conhecida em capa de revista pela
revista americana que central magazin
uma lista de referência nos estados
unidos e que eu vou a ter esse sonho
concretizado assim é quando isso
aconteceu o meu objetivo quando eu fiz o
convite o objetivo era fazer parte
daquela vista ponto nunca pensei que ia
chegar este esta situação é e entre
centenas de trabalhos foi escolhida para
esta capa foi algo que me deixou
realmente muito feliz cerca de uma hora
antes de os receber esse convite e ele
terminar nós nunca sabemos quem é que
está a ver o nosso trabalho e mostra de
e do outro lado do oceano havia alguém
observar o meu trabalho
não sei como eu um pontinho aqui um
ponto do texto desse oceano como é que
isto é possível e não sabia também que
na minha caixa de correio nesse mesmo
dia já mostrava um animal que por pouco
não a pagar porque pensei que era mais
um do que os venenos que o subchefe
publicidade eu abril e maio e de tão
incrédula que eu fiquei sem minar
despachou isto você se tornou realmente
isso eu leu fez aquela expressão tipo já
é isso eu cai os desafios aumentaram
quando eu percebi que tinha menos 15
dias para pôr o projeto em prática
tinha que olhar com uma viagem marcada
dominar passe e que tinha também que a
gerir com os nossos três filhos disse
que não ia fazer os meus sais nem as
mães e que concretizar mas este objetivo
e é assim foi uma das críticas muito
sobre joão em khan elas não sabe ela vai
faz e é pra eles e essa mesma
característica que ela foi além de todas
as coisas que eu tenha monte sinai
reserva não não vai
e ela decidiu avançar em uma das coisas
que ela faz muito em políticos que ela
tem conseguido avançar muito nesta área
é o fato de ela começar a arriscar e
aprender técnicas como ela está aqui em
nossas técnicas aprendidas para este
bolsa precifica a técnica dos cristais
de açúcar que ela não fazia melhor como
é que surge a aprender o momento e
conseguiu materializar este bolo e uma
coisa aqui portanto certeiro é nós temos
está disposto a pagar o preço não está
disposta a resistir em prol dos nossos
sonhos mas a rodada atual não é estanque
neste momento já é sentido algum tempo
uma nova intensidade nessa as nossas
células seus o nosso corpo se renovam xx
tem por que que eu enquanto pessoa tem
que usar uma câmera por mais de 40 anos
tal como as minhas células as minhas das
minhas necessidades dos meus desejos
missões também é nova porque cada um nós
não abraça é que o que me faz mais feliz
a sociedade está cheia de gente que não
é fácil acredita que causa está é muito
nesta situação as pessoas não fazem
porque essa paixão é verdadeiramente e
com formas poucos toca você no padrão
social e então eu fui muito que nós
vamos fazer o que os faz mais felizes
quem tem problemas e é isso que não vai
falar sobre nada
ao ganhar 2 minutos foi do que sobre o
qual é o seu verdadeiro eu menti e viveu
desde muito novo
sabia que em formato que é a sua
verdadeira paixão e ainda nos casarmos
já trabalhava numa empresa do funchal
como programador
eu lembro muito bem da etá muito
presente porque se é a minha
personalidade o amava o que fazia
é e o mar o que fazia eu fiz durante o
tempo que fazia mava e só campeão deseje
muito forte pra ensinar a vida passar
por novas experiências coisas que já
estavam sonhos por concretizar a e
lembro de um dia a lei só que aí eu
tenho que passar pelo próximo presidente
jacinto tem que me contentar uma pátria
na altura e hidro e quer falar contigo e
só eu que passei é só pra dizer
há muito tem som é o tipo de lá o que é
que se passa
isso é só para dizer que você está em
pré e não bate certo
como é que taxa tem que passar mal e não
simplesmente porque ficou muito mudar
vou mandar este próximo passo e eu quero
experimentar algo e foi isso que não vou
porque era uma experiência que queria
passar para lecionar aulas de
programação também os alunos um sonho
que tinha desde o décimo ano de sempre
mas quando eu aprender a programar eles
e eu também quero inspirar os alunos e
quer ensiná los a uma nova forma é
programar a criarem coisas incríveis e
fui como vou dar aulas nesta mesma
escola na escola da apel
durante cerca de oito anos inspirar
jovens e trazendo mais acredita mais nos
fazem coisas incríveis
literalmente mas também tudo é um circo
que siga o fim
após oito anos de montar um gabinete na
altura do do nosso diretor pedagógico eo
contato deles leonardo nós não podemos
continuar contigo e ciclo terminou já
não eram necessárias nos serviços não
tinha a ver com as minhas capacidades já
não eram sabe o curso tinha fechado
então a partir daí o que aconteceu foi
literalmente eu ir para uma escola
pública uma realidade diferente e diz o
que isto é mais tarde frentes você sabia
que a cada mudança ela canta [ __ ] para
algo maior
é uma oportunidade para rever é próximo
passo é próxima à montanha que tenha que
subir ea partir daí o que aconteceu foi
o seguinte 1 sentindo super super
satisfeito e um dia que cheguei a casa e
grande elenco e diz ah o amor
eu não quero ir dar aulas hoje a tatuí
mas então não faz mas eu disse que ia
pensar no seu espírito livre nunca
pensar nas consequências do incidente
eu ela disse aquilo que ele atingiu tão
profundamente uma coisa tão simples e
nós estamos no escritório falar e fui
pra ouvir por jardim florais simbolizam
que diz a 1 ao que sentem por um lado é
verdade que isso livro e sua escolha o
que quiser e renovou hoje nem vou nunca
mais eu decido que faz com a minha vida
isso livro ea partir daí consegue traçar
um plano como os próximos objetivos na
altura estava já desenvolveram um novo
projeto com é como sócio o antigo aluno
desta escola da apel
nós criamos uma rede social que narra a
história curta nós vamos é essa mesma
empresa sobre temas para conseguirmos ir
a um web summit na altura em tablet
elevada em 2015 e fomos escolhidos por
band entre centenas centenas de empresas
estavam lá em versão alfa e isso a nossa
falta aqui então nós fomos críticos e
nós temos aqui uma experiência incrível
e músicos importantes e que essa
experiência não era o ponto final ela o
faça nos ao próximo passo vai me a mim é
ver a próxima à montanha o próximo
caminho que tenha conseguido entrar
agora que exatamente tudo estou agora e
neste momento estou apple diz o
consultor de marketing digital e
trabalha internacionalmente com clientes
em portugal e noutros países e é nesse
momento que um cinto altamente inspirado
agora trabalhar com as pessoas estão
dizendo é brincadeira e outra melhor ela
costuma ser brincadeira e entrou no jogo
eu tenho o dom de ser um saca-rolhas eu
cheguei ao pé das pessoas deslocar eles
aquelas feitas todas e traz autoestima
de todos os dons talentos e paixões das
pessoas e coloca-os de forma brilhante
sanaa altíssima as pondo e tudo isso ao
mundo colocando forma equilibrada
mentalidade de tecnologia e até
espiritual dados forma profissional e
brilhantismo mas e sexy para nós temos
as nossas peças são diferentes
contudo as nossas aprendizagem são
semelhantes e é sobre isso que nós
partilhamos todos os dias em casal em
que nós não nos conformarmos com aquilo
que não satisfaz pe
procuramos a mudança rumo a novos
objetivos estão sempre atentos aos
sinais de vida eis que sempre conta o
que a nossa intuição
e super importantes não deixarmos o
sistema limitar os nossos sonhos e eu
queria deixar aqui com algum tempo eu
quis deixar um legado para os meus
filhos
e apesar de ela não gostava de dizer
isto é se uma morreu esta manhã o que
deixava os filhos mensagens poderiam
ouvir meus criam é que o que seria a
minha visão de sucesso a minha visão diz
pressas na vida do espírito livre e
feliz como fez criar um áudio por um
vídeo e depois gravar o contínuo e que
nós queremos partilhar convosco porque
se essa mensagem foi importado e
empurrando os meus filhos é pedir pra
vocês deve ficar alguma coisa então
deixo aqui com o vídeo nós fizemos
propostas 10 um sonho não é só e apenas
teu mesmo em outras pessoas deve
produtivo não pode ser salva por nada
nem por ninguém
ninguém tem direito nem o poder do faraó
mandatos o'neal
fora em alta quando o sonho em ajudar
outras pessoas e velas vencer
eu procuro quanto é sonho e sabe
exatamente do que queijo enquanto girar
não é um como deveria ser a pergunta
dizer o queijo brigadeiro a meio da vida
vivo com salvar essa menina agradece
tudo já thais valorizar as pequenas
coisas os clientes muitos sonhos grande
começa o que vejo na tv
cabeça nas estrelas se uniu e
acreditei em cima todas as coisas perdem
os dias vindouros o mundo aja agora
lembrando que nada pode ser um gracie
não existia de maio
hassan foi constante porque faço é
sempre melhor que faz não é deus entende
que esta missão é eu sei do que esta
dimensão
não estou então caí
agora então quando enquanto que está
surgindo um mês para lembrar que
atualmente serve para limpar uma
reciclagem para fazer os dados que é um
passo foi ver aquele grau de
aprendizagem branco vírus melhor opção
nós próprios e seu caminho e nesse
caminho de opção está na cidade de
benghazi um chip de se ver
não as ruas não estuda nasa espaço
quanto vale tem mais baseada no medo
total 21 6% do mundo em nosso deus
sucinto no nossa nem todas as respostas
do hepta todo mestre uma vez frio que
foi um dos astros muito provavelmente
a vida atletas press não quer só este é
o momento
[Música]
vivo intensamente acredita infinitamente
partilha incondicionalmente
beijos obrigado muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]